do you know an expecting mother in need
help of southern nevada has everything
they need to know
and need for a healthy delivery and
first year the organization is operating
a diaper bank
eligible mothers can receive diapers for
their child age
0 to 3. on average diapers cost 23
dollars a box and that quickly adds up
the group also has classes where women
can receive free car seats
advocates want to relieve the stress and
worrying surrounding an unplanned
pregnancy
a diaper is a basic need just like food
water and shelter is for adults that's
what it is for our youth and our babies
and it's the toughest decision a parent
has to make to keep their child in a
soiled diaper because they don't have
additional diapers
and so we have the ability here through
the diaper bank
uh help southern nevada's diaper bank to
provide diapers for any parent with
children under three years old
yeah it's a great program so to qualify
parents we'll need an id and social
security card for proof of child
you must also make an appointment before
stopping by their location it's over on
lake mead
we've got more details for you on eight
news now dot com